The meaningful use criteria promote
robust interoperability between the systems used by patients,
providers, and healthcare institutions.
Meaningful use stages progressively demand
compliance with this patient engagement framework,
or PEF, developed by
the HIMSS Foundation and the National eHealth Collaborative that are now merged.
You can see how the stages of meaningful use align with the PEF.
Stage one of meaningful use,
the Engage Me phase of the PEF,
specifies that patients can view and download their electronic health record.
Stage two, the Empower Me phase of the PEF,
is far more ambitious,
and specifies integration with the Health Information Exchange,
or HIE, our next topic,
as well as e-referral coordination among providers,
ambulatory and hospital records integration,
the addition of images and video to EHRs,
and the inclusion of data from commercial labs, radiology, and pharmacies.
We're currently quite far away from having all of this everywhere,
but each of these capabilities is available in at least some places.
Presumably because of Meaningful Use,
a New York study showed the reported rate of PHR use increased from 11 percent,
2012 to 17 percent, 2013.
More directly to the point,
the proportion of the PHRs provided by doctors or
healthcare organizations increased sharply from 50 percent,
2012 to 73 percent in 2013.
This research also showed that the mean age of PHR users was 47.2 years,
51 percent were female,
and 80 percent had a physician who used the HRs.